what's up reject nation I'm Greg this is
Greg - Greg 3 we are going to watch
stranger things
I forgot what episode this is it's in
the title of the video all right if you
can give this spiel before you know
what's coming make sure to subscribe and
click that notification bellow so you
can be notified whenever we have a
stranger things reaction up which should
be tomorrow based off of the way this is
all going secondly thank you to Eric
over at neurotic for editing these
reaction highlights for us YouTube only
allows for 10 minutes worth of reaction
footage to go up so our stream alongs
for this latest season are all going up
on our patreon page and over there we do
stream along for several shows those are
Cobra Kai season 2 haunting of Hill
House Gotham we cover several shows as
well where we have stream alongs and
reaction highlights included those are
my hero academia attack on Titan Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood one punch
man
basically anime plus the supernatural
and Eric he's done work for people like
Eamon snow åkesson and movie trivia
schmidt down he has podcaster /
podcaster found like on YouTube as well
so make sure to give him a follow at
nerve chronic let's get to this now
shall we kids
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
to him
how big is that assassin seems so scary
is an assassin or whatever the [ __ ] he
is like the [ __ ] terminator this is
[Music]
[Music]
he's totally a riff on the term damn how
does about it I know
[Music]
well the play on that bit because
usually with that joke they did like
throw out the window or something by
accident but she checked it right to the
bad guy yeah I wonder if my theory from
episode wants me to be correct about
that scientists are currently here that
he'd become a good guy maybe first
heavenly who looks like you've got it
become a good guy venture mm-hmm and now
he's kidnapped me be safe
[Music]
[Music]
Jesus
[Music]
what whoa what the hell oh oh they got
transition I love Heather buddies
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
damn they're all coming together
[Laughter]
let's see
I should have grabbed another one the
mind flayer place people takes over
their mind what to do that they
basically become him if there are two
fully have to assume there are more
Heather
[Music]
a 1980
[Music]
hot you killed murdered source she wants
to come back so gotta get a white Walker
and take it to Cersei is it the guy from
seasons here yet the magically see you
small in seconds
[Music]
yay I like this guy
[Music]
well man with the Russians Red Dawn
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
Steve 1:11 killer yeah blow it blow it
Mike
what does he always have like a serial
killer I'm gonna [ __ ] win you bet
don't worry the last episode it's gonna
be a bleeding nose from him oh we will
Oh
[Music]
oh I don't think they can write for The
Washington Post anymore okay Washington
foes whatever it's called et that was on
purpose
starting Terminator
[Music]
[Music]
that chairs
[Music]
goddamn
[Music]
[Music]
you destroy him destroy his head
[Music]
Oh
come out of that ap
like video game villains you kill them
again oh no oh it's gonna [ __ ] all died
Alma
whoa
[Music]
Wow oh yeah and this has to be the best
shot best edited season they've done so
far I'm loving the way everything is
composed I think it was like season 2
when second a last episode before all
them got back together maybe not all
them are here right now but most of them
are back together at this point this is
probably my favorite Nancy episode I'd
say out of the ones we've seen so far
I actually prefer her in the position of
leader of the kids as opposed to
whatever dynamics she has going on with
her and Jonathan hey yeah the half my
brain was scratching itself during that
scene going are they gonna possess
Jonathan hurt killed Jonathan off I was
thinking they might go there I'm like
maybe that's why Jonathan's been
thinking a bit of a backseat dump
cocaine on top what you guys why you
brought this on yourself
real-life actor oh I have my own thing
in that moment actually cuz yeah they
make it look really bleak and I think
that's a nifty way to pull us out of
there where she clocks Gary Busey and it
gives him the crucial moment to perhaps
not be destroyed by the yes so it that's
I mean by the editing of it was so well
done to solve their problem though have
to just like every season they have to
go to the main source gotta go to the
main if it works like a hive mind
especially you get that all all the
people reacting any punch in the face
it's another one of those things where
it makes you ask kind of the same
questions as us does where you're like
so are they all doing that like no
matter where they are yeah there's a
bunch of random people like across town
in front of their friends here's the
thing though are they clones or are they
take are their bodies taken over and
after they're taken over they are like
possessed by these things and then
they're Russians
[Laughter]
I have monitor is Russian yeah I had
been taking it as though it yeah it like
infects you so when they killed Gary
Busey's character and didn't realize now
that's the way I took that so then now
I'm like I wonder if this was a setup
really so like like now what they're
gonna have to like kill Billy like am i
yes or on they get it out of him yet
yeah I'm like because like now I they
got to kill all of those people or can
they get it out of I took it as if they
were being cloned because in the first
episode or was a second one where
everyone were Billy Billy sees an
alternate version he sees the other
version of himself or maybe that is just
like the spiritual connection thing with
the other realm and you know what as
much as the show has been showing that
like the Russians are opening it back up
which would make sense why all this is
happening
you're right that I probably wouldn't be
too surprised if like they did some
reveal that it was like oh no they're
actually trying to solve the problem
it's like mislead yeah the only thing
that made me wonder that partly is a I
mean of course like who are were
designed to think Oh evil Russians are
gonna open the portal because they're
not and maybe just set it up and you
don't spend time with them yeah but I
was thinking like all we see in that
shot we don't see what the portal is
doing it doesn't look like it's
expanding or contracting so it's very
vague when they're firing into it I'm
just reading into color symbolism but
like the green liquid that like acid
dissolves concrete is what they're
putting in to power this machine is this
some kind of laser meant to destroy this
- oh is it breaking through again and
they're trying to contain it I don't
know why they're Russian it's one of
those things where I'm like oh I should
be they've got [ __ ] is this
yeah this is the America this is gonna
unite the world this came out all things
worse a lot if I can change you can
share it but I can share and by the end
of the season the big guys gonna be the
new part of the cast
yeah it's I've noticed with this season
they've been way more with calling out
their references then just letting the
references live it's kind of read done
and then Dustin calls it out it's kind
of like Arnold and
it seems like they're very aware of like
everyone knows about the references and
what we're riffing on so we might as
well just call out ourselves this time
around which i think does work for
itself but it also some time for like a
split second pulls me out it makes me
think of I'm aware of what they're doing
now yeah the thing that saved that for
me is you know in the binge watching
experience especially it's like I didn't
really have a great recollection of that
guy's face so when he showed back up I
was like oh he does look just like
Arnold yeah so I got a little mileage
out of it but yeah they are they are
kind of on the nosing somewhere omage
this this season definitely made me
think of the thing and even when yes on
a Testament episode don't like the blood
tests everything with hopper and like
Joyce's becoming a very strong character
yeah I like how she cuz you know like
especially with the first season she was
just kind of this really frantic on edge
woman they seem like they've taken a lot
of their female characters and made them
a lot stronger this time around it
really hit me hard of how I'm loving how
eleven is just a girl and this message
it's not just something like like she's
never has been but it's kind of a they
kind of treat her that way and that's
understandable based off the psychology
of what she was going through and I
think it's her relationship with Max has
really helped flush that out she's just
a regular girl this time around who just
also happens to have these eleven
abilities that she has yeah and that's
really nice progression I think out of
season two cuz you get all that like in
season one she's got no place to be in
season two she's got one very specific
place to be and then now she has to
actually have flourish again still
despite all the cool intrigue and stuff
I'm like yeah I love it when they're
just like getting together and doing
girl things together and having yeah
those character developments have you
noticed that Hopper and Joyce haven't
had all been like gotta get back to work
it's called
check on Jonathan she asked about will
he got a call a check on will
she knows she's like the upside down
people they don't want Jonathan fine is
what and then why Susie a she was so
overprotective and now I think she's
learning from that experience as she's
going you know what Will's got this yeah
he's faced off with so many things
they'll be fine no like I wonder how
that my kid eleven who has
well I think the funny thing about this
episode this season it's one of the more
immediate totally it's a great point
it's one of the more immediate it's one
of the more immediate seasons so there's
like no time lapses or any time jumps in
between episodes you're kind of just
right so everyone has like a new costume
this season you kind of like the ahoy
kasi open you got a hopper and it's like
magnum p.i outfit I'm really loving all
that as that it's whole make oh yes
exactly everyone's got like a little
costume I kind of feel like Mike this
season has primarily just been
complaining or like angry but he hasn't
been much of a character other than the
guy who just like annoyed frustrated
angry here's like John about his
girlfriend also the world's ending oh it
seems like he's hasn't kind of much
character work here yeah I'm like put
your riffin wolf are you're the main
dude just a one-note character this
season and I don't think it's his fault
it seems like it's the writing that
hasn't given him much to do again it may
be one of those things symptomatic of
like in the first couple seasons
especially the first season I feel like
Mike was one of the main you know
central characters and so especially now
the Elevens journey is partly about not
being defined by Mike yeah he is kind of
off to the side now whenever we check
back in with him it's just him and Lucas
basically either being like man we're a
dick to will or man girls right yeah but
I like that adolescent journey there
because I feel like it's a very natural
progression yeah really go through yeah
yeah yeah that's a good point
that was part of where my mind went too
cuz I like how everyone stole all their
likes what are they doing as girls you
know yeah in the midst of all this
although they're just good I love hat I
like how we'll always just seems like
he's in a good mood until it's like
something starts to happen always I
imagine right when he has calmed down
he's like you know what it's gonna be
all right
but that whole Hospital sequence was
great to know that was really well done
I was pretty scary and how that was all
forming and I can't wait to find out
what the hell's going on exactly
there's no one else work in that
hospital no they're all one nurse
they're all dead on that floor I've
worked in the hospital so that's just so
illogical but this is an 80s Hospital
yeah where nobody had job and I will say
Arnold reference guy is pretty scary
keep moving on you know let's just keep
moving on let's keep it Oh Murray's back
Murray that's Ronnie back hell yeah
speaks Russian I'm honestly very happy
he's back because he progressed Jonathan
and Nancy last season but hoping he
progresses very happy feelings of joy
sand hoppers yeah yeah more appropriate
encouragement of love and Alexi is gonna
take the puck all right guys well make
sure to subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell so you can
notify when our next stranger things
reaction is a patron today shout out to
since I put out that postive yeah okay
you've heard me met you before if you've
come this far
most likely Niraj Krishnan John I'm
gonna let you take this one I've taken
the lead on all the other five Niraj
thanks for joining us if you joined us
you said you were gonna watch stranger
things and if you don't we're gonna find
you and we're gonna beat the crap out of
you man because you're making us look
like idiots right now so I trust that
you're enjoying the show let us know how
it is out there on the east coast cuz
one of the hardest things out here is
waking up super early mornings Pacific
Time why don't you just like shoot us
stuff early man like harness the power
of time and space with watching stranger
things get us some how to have your time
zone on our coasts this shoutouts going
everybody
makes sense I literally lock into a
stream of consciousness and then when
Greg tells me to stop that's when I
stopped so I wanna hook up with an
Indian guy you let me down you guys
totally gonna throw my god you guys all
just mean the guy is Greg another
reality but she will call you Indian you
call me this will be a weird answer